[Musique]
non mais vous faites partie des non
inscrits il n'y a plus de temps de
parole carole bureau bonnart présidente
de séance à l'assemblée nationale a
suivi le règlement jean lassalle député
non inscrit n'avait plus de temps de
parole sur le projet de loi sur le
logement
c'est ce qui est honteux c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de faire monsieur la
salle vous n'avez pas à vous lever et à
hurler dans l'assemblée le béarnais
privé de micro s'est mise en colère pour
faire entendre son avis il ya ici 50
députés qui ne servent à rien c'est
honteux vous poussez un vieux ça vous
tenir tête et s'il vous plaît calmez
vous calmez vous je vous expliquais le
règlement il a poursuivi l'assemblée
nationale du peuple français doit
respecter le droit à l'expression des
députés s'il vous plaît ce soir où
sortent les présidents de séance a
demandé aux députés de quitter
l'hémicycle je vous remercie au revoir
me remerciez pas madame ménard jean
lassalle a fini par s'exécuter avec
mesdames messieurs les censeurs bonsoir
jean lassalle se considère aujourd'hui
comme un sou députés
[Musique]